is it ok to have periods where you don't
feel passionate or feel passionate about
doing nothing yeah why did I understand
actually I'm some stage with a guy
called Sir Richard Branson ooh my
constituents what a duty one as well and
so humble he's got such a sense of
humility he's so grounded attention are
it was amazing but I just think I asked
her the question you know he was his
first business was when it's 16 he's now
think 66 50 years of being an
entrepreneur and he's had hundreds of
brands across what virgin america Liz
down music verge of Music sign people
like Rolling Stones sick first all of
these pants I'm so many business I like
to ask him there must have been times
where you had really dark here as you
career and you lost that you know since
it have with your sense of passion was
doused and your heart you know struggle
so how did you overcome that out of your
bounce back and I think it does come
back to what we talked about you've got
to have that sense of passion that sense
of flow from that mission the noble
cause that you want to create the reason
why you know you see a gap in the market
you're angry or there's pain and you can
solve that and inevitably unit we're all
human beings and we all have some bad
days and sometimes we get knocked off
I'll kind of mission when you do that
again I think you need some people
around it where you can just have the
honest conversation and you always find
when you talk stuff through it's never
as bad as it seems and then that gives
you the courage to come back and push
you your noble cause yeah I think it's
okay to have some down days like I don't
want to paint it to view this rosy
picture everything is amazing all the
time and you always win but if you are
down for too long like if you are not
motivated for too long if you look in
the mirror and you're you're depressed
for too long then something probably has
to change you know I have down days in
my business you know the video that we
put up I didn't like as much as it
because it could be you know
perfectionist and want things to be
better always I don't have a bigger
impact always but i still love what I do
you a lot and then I get lost in the
work again so back to like loving the
craft counting on it beatin on it loving
what you do and not being so attached to
the results so yes you're going to have
down days but if you don't on your
surface like if that happens too many
days in a row then something probably
needs a shift in your life somewhere
yeah and and always I think about life
we only get one shot I mean I don't it
but it's great to be optimist and I
think your optimism particularly when
you start employing people and you
growing optimism is contagious and
people will look to you and when you
walk in on a monday morning leave on a
friday they'll know whether you're
walking with a bouncing year your stride
or whether you walk with your head down
and your heart sunk they'll feel the
energy and i think as a leader
inherently tivoli there is a correlation
between optimism and success and you've
got to obviously not just customers
partners keeping social media but our
ultimate your colleagues if your
colleagues love your mission and your
passion they'll follow you to the ends
of the earth and if you you actually
praised them and give them the tools to
be successful and surround them with
optimism then I'm not going to you kid
yourself in genuine optimism to great
power and a force for good